Speaker 1: Let's hear from a couple of
other people. Why don't we go to Nathan
from California? Nathan, you're on the air.
Speaker 9: Hey, David. I work in the wedding
industry and a recently a local politician has
caught some flack on the news for attending a
private event. And I just wanted to know what
your thoughts on kind of like the hypocrisy
of politicians saying that you
should wear a mask indoors while
they're attending these private events?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, there's obvious
hypocrisy. There's no question about it. Also,
sometimes public health guidelines are supported
at a governmental level and individuals assess
their own risk and they do different things.
I mean, OK, you know, it doesn't make it not
hypocritical. It just is something that happens.
I don't know about the event. You know, sometimes
people go to I've gone to a couple of events where
everybody's got to be vaccinated and gets a test
on the way in. And then like, I went to a dinner
with 10 people like that last month, and that
seemed quite reasonable. And and we don't know
what the testing requirement is. I'm about to go
to a wedding where everybody's going to be tested.
So I don't know. I mean, of course, there's some
level of hypocrisy. And then at the same time,
I think a lot of the stuff is in the details.
Speaker 9: OK. I mean, do you think
like at a certain point, the personal
responsibility will be kind of like the
data ultimately is the thing that
people want to take upon themselves
outside of, like these mass mandates?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think it's
going to go more and more in that direction. And
like Dr. Isaac Bogoch last week told us, once we
really have a high enough level of vaccination and
hopefully the virus becomes less serious where the
death risk goes down even more, then it becomes
more about each individual making that decision
for themselves. We're not at that point right now
for a number of different reasons. The virus is
still far more serious than the flu, and not not
nearly enough people are vaccinated. So yes, it's
going to go more and more towards just personal
decisions, but we're nowhere near that yet.
Speaker 9: Awesome. Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Very good question.
Appreciate it. All right. Thanks to everybody
who called in. That's going to do it for today.
We'll take calls again and I'll speak to more
people. We'll take a quick break and be right back